à quelques heures de ce cinquième rendez
gilet jaune
difficile de dire quelle sera l'ampleur
du mouvement à pontarlier une demande de
manifestation a été déposé la réponse
n'est pas encore arrivé mais une chose
est sûre mathieu bourgeois et d'autres
gilet jaune seront bien dans la rue il y
aura déjà pas de blocage complet
ce sera pas ralentissement voilà
ralentissement qui au barrage filtrant
même si à pontarlier le dialogue a
toujours prévalu
le mouvement a perturbé le commerce dans
les zones le 17 novembre et les trois
samedis suivants des pertes inégale d'un
magasin à l'autre
quant à muro responsable d'une grande
enseigne de sport on a eu en effet une
perte de chiffre d'affaires mais qui
sait compenser avec le site internet qui
se compensent aussi avec la semaine avec
un fuir un peu plus importants notamment
le soir après l'école
après une bonne année 2017 2018 a été
plus contrastée pour les commerçants du
centre-ville pour qui les fêtes de fin
d'année sont primordiales béatrice
saillard de l'union des commerçants on
sait pas ce qui va se passer demain on
espère que les clients vont venir faire
leurs achats au centre-ville parce que
c'est très important pour sauvegarder
l'emploi l'économie locale est
importante donc on espère une
manifestation à fait blancs peur mais
beaucoup de commerçants le reconnaissent
les gilet jaune ne sont pas seuls
responsables de ce marasme
nathalie wendel commerçante dans la
principale rue de pontarlier y voit une
tendance plus globale
à mon avis c'est multifactoriel c'est
internet seller gilet jaune voilà les
gilets jaunes ça n'aide parts assez sûr
pour demain nouvelle manif a priori vous
êtes inquiète inquiète nan mais c'est
fatigant c'est usant il reste dix jours
avant noël pas de quoi rattraper le
retard perdu mais la boutique de
nathalie comme beaucoup d'autres sera
ouverte tous les jours dimanche compris